today on our show we got a guest in the
fat cave you just wait you just wait
we'll be right back
[Music]
hey woman a fat man I'm Batman I'm mark
barnard and that is not Kevin Smith I'm
pretty sure you can tell that's not
Kevin Smith Kevin is up doing fancy
Kevin things wherever Kevin does fancy
Kevin things I'm assuming it's Canada it
feels like Canada is where Kevin looks
fancy but for today we have comic book
writer impresario mark on Draco and a
fellow mark with a seat fella mark with
the ceiling we got to stay together
there's a club we have jackets and
everything we're gonna talk to mark
today about a ton of [ __ ] about about
Batman Wonder Woman death of Hawkman and
the amazing love is love charity book
that he did with DC and IDW but first
let's go all the way back okay let's
let's talk about the beginnings let's
talk about your first comic book you can
remember reading amazing spider-man
number 136 featuring of the cover with
Peter Parker facing off against Harry
Osborn and it's when Harry Osborn took
on the mantle of the Green Goblin for
the first time I remember I was four
years old on an airplane to Boston with
my mom and I remember reading that well
looking at not necessarily reading but
looking at the comic book cuz that's my
that's my very first memory of comics
that's awesome now what what about the
medium do you think entranced you as a
kid well you know I had an older cousin
who I was kind of always following
around that he was the comic book reader
so when you're of a certain age of copy
things and you know between Sesame
Street and spider-man comics and
spider-man on The Electric Company
that's how I learned to read and it was
just it was just a great way to see
these stories come to life and it gave
you you know comic books when we were
kids people like all comic books are rot
your brain my parents were always like
read whatever you want as long as you're
reading so by the time I was in the
third grade I had a twelfth grade
reading level because I was using words
like a Ragnarok and apocalypse equation
well because of comic books so there
they've been they've been a part of my
life as far back as I have conscious
memories can you remember the first time
you realized that somebody made comic
books do you remember the first like
writers name oh yeah absolutely my mom's
friend sent me
an interview with Stanley from National
Geographic and I was like oh my god I
could be a poops in his ear ya know
nobody was it was laying on the bed
doing the Burt Reynolds Cosmo centerfold
but it was a whole article about how
comic books are written and it made me
give that behind-the-scenes sort of
thing you know we're spoiled now because
we now know what Tom Hanks had for lunch
today with the internet and all them the
different media and back then it was a
big deal because how many books still
weren't respected and I remember calling
Marvel Comics when I was like 10 like a
Stan Lee available and then he answered
the phones like hello so yeah that was
the first time I remember be I still
have the article I still have a folded
up article torn out of a National
Geographic from 1978 maybe No so now
connect the dots for me from you know
four-year-old mark who's reading
spider-man to ten year-old mark who's
reading the National Geographic for the
articles to actually like your first
baby steps into here's what I'm going to
try and do for a living well as a kid I
didn't you know my friends and I would
do our own comic books on our little you
know spiral notebooks and Trapper
Keepers and stuff and I initially wanted
to be a comic artist but I just don't
have the natural inclination or the
discipline to do what artists do I can
visualize things and do rudimentary
thumbnails but being a full-time artist
is just a skill set I don't have and I
never really wanted to be a writer you
know I majored in theater in college and
this is the my first big comics job and
this is a story I hate telling because I
know I went to Kent State University yes
that one in Ohio and P Craig Russell
lives there and I became friends with
him and I remember it was in the mid 90s
and we were talking Marvel was doing
really cool stuff then and he had done a
Doctor Strange annual in 1974 that he
had originally written and drawn and I
guess I got put in a drawer and then
Marv Wolfman came in and Reese crypted
it and Craig it was not the story Craig
originally wanted to tell so I said well
why don't you do a call Marvel and say
you want to do a director's cut and
redraw the ending the way you wanted to
it's good idea then I get a call from
him a couple days later again Marvel
said yes we're gonna do the book I'm
like oh that's awesome he's like well
when can you start
he said what he's like you're gonna
write it with me so is that Rita
Hayworth at Schwab's terrific screw you
so that was my entree into Cohn
yes so pretty love it to be a star yeah
I know it's I know it's annoying but uh
but that was my first my first you know
step into the pond was with P Craig
Russell Doctor Strange and Marvel Comics
so I kind of lucked into it and that's
about it when was that that was 1993 Wow
yeah maybe two ninety three yeah very
cool and so after that after that became
like the break-in story I broke in what
happens after the breaking story like I
know that there's a bunch of people out
there who'd like I want to get into
comics I wanted I want to do the thing
I've got ideas I got stories like a
Batman series of the yin-yang and maybe
they get that first bite at the Apple
but then they sort of flounder after
that so for you how was the the building
a career well I thought it was gonna be
a one and done you know I would you know
I wanted to know when I graduated from
college I produced and directed a lot of
theater and worked on production and
movies and stuff but I wrote that story
and then I was with some other buddies
of mine because there are a lot of comic
people in Kent and I had this I was
always kind of obsessed with what almost
was the movie The Lost Boys it was
originally it was Peter Pan and then it
became the Joel Schumacher sort of
glittering hair the thing that it was I
still believed exactly who was on the
cover of one of the issues of the most
amazing tawny Harris drew him the oily
sax player added you so i pit you know i
pitched this idea of like you know i
would love to do a peter pan story a
contemporary one and then we did that as
an independent comic so i was just kind
of baby steps in that and then after the
doctor strange annual came out an editor
at Marvel named Joe Andriano
called me to do a Wolverine story at a
black and white Wolverine story with
this Italian artist that was fun and
then I just started getting calls and it
just became oh this can be a way to to
scratch the creative itch and make money
and let me pursue let me work on movies
for 50 bucks a day because I've got this
and then you know I had no interest in
being a writer because but once I was a
director I realized that oh it's just
easier for me to try and write these
stories than micromanage other friends
you know here's an idea do it and bring
it back to me know that never ends well
never goes well and somehow I convinced
people other whether through a Jedi mind
trick or blind luck that I was decent at
what I did and the rest as they say is
you know history or misery to
talk to me now how do you I mean I know
you've done some creator-owned stuff I
know you you also found great success
doing company characters how do you I
mean personally find the new things to
get excited about in characters that
have been around for 70 80 90 years well
it's a mixture of going after characters
that I like you know that everybody's
got a Batman story they want to tell or
a Superman story or a spider-man story
and actually none of those characters
interest me on a monthly basis because I
think there's so much pressure to try
and write you know how bad there's so
many stories that have been told with
Batman I hats off to these guys like
Scott Snyder or Tom King who gonna write
long runs of them and tell fresh stories
but I like characters are off the beaten
path and some of the most interesting
and most successful things for me have
been characters have been brought to me
I was originally working on Thunder
agents at DC and there were rights
issues and it kind of fell apart we had
three issues in the cam and it fell
apart and a week later Dan DiDio who's
kind of my godfather in this business
he's been great to me called me and said
I want to do Manhunter I'm like don't
you have 15 of them woman I'm like good
luck with that and then I was watching
TV and there was a story about Katharine
Hepburn and I just watched prime suspect
I said okay I'm gonna pitch him
something and see if he likes it and so
I pitched the attorney in Los Angeles
and used the metaphor of you know
supervillain crime for celebrity crime
and that's the thing before love is love
that I was most known for and you know
when Dan asked me if I wanted to death
of Hawkman with that I'm strange I'm
like and now I want to do an Adam
Strange book because he's so much fun
so the unexpected characters characters
you have no expectation and writing tend
to be the ones that are the most fun for
me because I don't have preconceived
notions I don't have history on my
shoulder I don't have the death of Gwen
Stacy or Dark Phoenix or the Judas
contract staring over my shoulder so I
can I get some freedom with these
characters and the same thing with
Wonder Woman I wrote Wonder Woman in
Manhunter and I was like this is gonna
be terrifying and Wonder Woman is so
much fun to write it same thing up I did
in right wing annual and now you know I
realized Oh Dick Grayson is like the
glue of the DC Universe so it's been
happy accidents what do you think I mean
I there have been conversations going on
for years and years and years about
female heroes and and how writing them
can be difficult writing sometimes the
DC Trinity can be hard because there
have been so many stories about them so
what's your lever into writing Batman or
Wonder Woman for you
well my lever under writing a character
is writing the character and not the
adjective first I don't write female
characters or gay characters or black
characters or straight characters I
write characters who happen to be and
because as a gay man being gay is a huge
part of who I am but it's also an
utterly insignificant part of who I am
there's so much more to everybody about
that so you try and serve the character
I think when you put the adjective first
you run the risk of being didactic and
you know you need to have a spoonful of
sugar or the medicines really bitter I
don't need someone lecturing me but if
you can find things that resonate
through the metaphor and the hidden
stuff that's under all the genre it's
really it's really satisfying so I try
and see what about this character do I
share do I relate to or or so the
opposite of me that I want to explore
that with Manhunter I don't agree with
her politics but that was what was fun
to write you know sometimes the best
arguments you can argue for things that
you love because you know what the
arguments are so that's kind of my
general rule try and write the character
and let and put the adjectives second in
a secondary position so tell me about
your your death of Hawkman run tell me
what the story is
tell me well the story is that Adam
Strange has been stuck on earth and this
is something's wrong with the Zeta beams
and his issue is on earth he's just as
dude he's just an archaeologist but in
outer space
he's Flash Gordon he's a superhero and
that's the direct opposite of katar Hall
on earth he's Hawkman a superhero but
back on his home planet he's just a beat
cop so there's sort of the yin and yang
of each other and there's been the
history of animosity between ran and
Fanny Garr and I really didn't want to
do the ran thanagar war again I wanted
to do something that played with the
expectations there and they you know
they said well what about can you use
Despereaux in and I'm like oh yeah
because I remember Despereaux from when
Adam Hughes did it you know and those
Justice League issues where Despereaux
was terrifying and I wanted to make
Despereaux an omega-level threat and I
knew up hawkman had to die at the end
for stuff that I'm sure will be going on
well my paygrade that I don't know about
also the title and the title but it was
great because the original title was out
of time Adam Strange and doctor and um
and Hawkman and then Dan was like well
we call it what it is call it death of
Hawkman and yeah there's sometimes
there's truth in advertising but it was
fun because I've never really written
any hardcore sci-fi before it's not
really what I'm known for or what I
gravitate towards as a reader but it was
so much fun writing this sort of Lethal
Weapon in space with big cosmic effects
out of it and I got to work with a great
team Aaron Lopresti who is one of the
most underrated artists in comics who is
not only has such a great design sense
but he's fast
these were 24 page issues you know he
was doing a lot of work we had to get a
guy a couple guys to help out as later
because he was just you know there's
only so many hours in the day but it was
I'm really proud of the book I think
it's a really fun science fiction book
that I think will satisfy Hawkman fans
and I well I didn't write it cuz I hate
Hawkman I wrote it because I love
Hawkman so how what is your what is how
do you work with an artist where is your
preferred way to work with an artist do
you are you a full script person you
know plot person like how much back and
forth for like how much there is I'm not
even gonna say a tendency but there are
writers who write books as if it's you
know script as gospel do what it says
and there are other writers you know who
absolutely just say I kind of want a
helicopter here but if you don't want to
draw a helicopter that's fine
like where do you land on it on the Stan
Lee vs. like Alan Moore kind of right in
the middle I tend to let the artist to
find the relationship they want to have
with me because I don't I'm not an
artist so I don't want to tell them what
to do in for example on the 38 issues of
Manhunter I wrote there's maybe 10 pages
where I wrote specific layouts where
this is how it should look
I look at it where I'm the director of
the film but the artist is a director of
photography and I tell them what I want
and no matter it doesn't matter how we
get there if you can get it across and
I'm also a writer who I try not to be
Precious about my writing it's a visual
medium at 51% at minimum so if I can cut
dialogue nothing makes me happier unless
it's not you know very rarely do I say
this has to be in there so it depends
this book because it was so we were
jumped right into it was very plot heavy
was it was a little
more scripty than marvel style but it
wasn't full script and it allowed Aaron
some freedom to show off his chops and
allowed me to have find some happy
accidents in it so it very much depends
on who the artist is some artists like
full scripts with very detailed things
some artists like some wiggle room and a
room to improvise and it just really
depends I let them to I led them to find
the relationship because they're gonna
be spending more time drawing it than I
am writing it no matter what so if I try
to put myself there as a resource that
they can use or not as they want about
how long do you I mean this is a total
that's involved write a question but no
matter how long does it take you to
write a draft of the script the writing
of the draft of the script is fairly
quickly or fairly quick the the the part
that takes the longest is what I call
the crockpot
part of it I get the idea I put it in
the Britain in there and let it simmer
on slow for a couple of weeks and let it
let all the good flavors rise out but
the actual physical writing is fairly
quick sometimes there's hiccups as you
all you know there's always that one
page that one sequence that you write 9
or 10 times and then you end up going
back to the one you wrote first but for
the most part it's the the physical
writing process is fairly quick it's
just the shaping and the idea and paring
down what you need to do in my head
that's the the long part so tell me
about the genesis of love is love aside
from the fact that it was inspired by
the Orlando pulse shooting well
basically what happened was the night of
the shootings I was going to bed and I
saw on the news that there was a
shooting at a club and I'm like I was
shooting in a club in America it must be
a day in America and then I woke up the
next morning and saw forty nine people
dead 53 injured and I and I got
physically ill and as a child of the 80s
of we are the world and comic relief my
reflex was I went on Facebook and said
we need to do something let's do a comic
book and I'll organize it if people want
to help and then it was Gay Pride that
weekend in LA and I haven't gone to that
in years because I've aged out of it but
uh but Paul Dini and his wife said hey
are you okay and I'm like yeah I said I
feel like I need to go to Gay Pride and
not be a shows up worth like run our way
over so we've spent the day there and
then I came home and there were 75
emails and Facebook messages saying
we're in it was actors writers directors
artists editors publishers all saying
we're in and I was like oh [ __ ] I guess
I'm making a book
and looking at it now I'm amazed at how
beautiful it is for in less than six
months it went from this sort of I need
to do something because I feel so
helpless to this great book that's gonna
generate hundreds of thousands of
dollars to help people out and the
caliber of people in this book I mean
you've got you've got Grant Morrison
you've got Mark Millar you about Brian
Bendis you've got Mike almond you've got
JK Rowling allowed us to use a quote
from a Harry Potter book and Jim Lee
drew Harry Potter characters what world
do I have the ability to help that
happen and it wouldn't have happened
without Diane Nelson at DC she reached
out to me and said we want to we'll do
whatever we can we want to publish this
we want you can use our characters Chris
rile and IDW said let's do this so they
took the little reigns with the
publishing of it with assistance from DC
jamieric the executive editor at vertigo
and Sarah Gaydos who's the Hasbro editor
at IDW both incredibly talented editors
who are editing at any given time
fifteen or twenty books said we want to
do this the book wouldn't exist without
them because I know I have a good
rolodex I know people but I don't know a
Jif from at if from the yeah and they
did it you know I told them I said you
guys need to put the order of the pages
and you order you think you guys need to
know the rhythms of that I'll sign off
on it but that's what you guys do and it
was just this thing where you know I'm
gonna try not to cry talking about it
but it just it truly is love is love
this is a labor of love and there was
next to no editing these are all pieces
that sprung a fully-formed from everyone
because whether you were gay or straight
or black or white or trans or male or
female everybody responded to this and
there was a little bit of controversy
from some LGBT people that I don't want
to hear white splaining about this I
said this isn't this isn't about that
this is this is an issue that affected
the LGBT community but it's a human
issue and everybody has a reaction to
this and everybody should and reading
the book it's a hard read because the
emotions are so raw and so real but I I
couldn't be prouder if this is the only
thing that's on my gravestone I will die
a happy man because the level of success
in my wildest dreams we wouldn't have de
beauté and
were one of the New York Times
bestseller list or be going into a fifth
printing you know I had friends who was
telling off-camera who were at Emerald
City con artists and writers who worked
on the book and they all tweeted me all
weekend saying I've signed so many
copies of the book people love this book
it's so humbling to see how many people
are grateful one of the kids who was
killed his mom called me and that's what
you know to be able to I can't imagine
losing a child
mm-hm and you call someone in banking on
yeah I don't deserve that you know I'm
glad I could do it it's just an amazing
thing so yeah like I went to the signing
yeah a live Golden Apple and it was it
was packed to the gills it was the
biggest signing golden apples head in
ten years
yeah on a rainy Wednesday the first week
after Christmas yeah I mean it was just
nothing but love just people who like
won the book and wanted to talk to
people about the book and wanted to just
talk to each other this weird communal
awesome little blue eBay's of people who
were either behind the scenes or just
consumers or just fans or just people
who felt drawn to it and that's what's
lovely especially in the world being so
divisive right now seeing people come
together to do something to help and to
do it
because they want to not because they
feeling they they're not forced to the
generosity is off the charts
every single person who contributed to
this book if they ever need help hiding
a body or need bone marrow or a kidney
I'll do it I'm there something tells me
you will be doing lots of like LAX runs
yeah exactly exactly I'm an uber driver
now and so and also this book got you on
television oh yeah television absolutely
crazy um yeah uh taran killam who is an
actor it was on Saturday Night Live and
I did a comic book with him called the
illegitimate as one of my dear friends
and we had tried we were trying to get
media attention for the book and DC's
publicist the great Kelly Popham who
will soon one day be our boss because
she she's so good at what she does it's
slightly annoying they sent it and they
were gonna they were booked until
January and then Taryn got it to Seth
and Seth said no I want him on now and
then they said oh good Terrans gonna be
on then Kelly said no they want you on
too but oh how many times am I gonna get
to be on Seth Meyers like I had known
Seth so
we threw teryn over the years but yeah
we got to be on Seth Meyers and you know
and Seth I I say watching Seth work I
felt like Salieri at the end of the day
s because he in the four minutes we were
on the air deftly handled everything we
covered in the 40-minute pre-interview
and when you're on when you're talking
to him you're the only person in the
room he knows his stuff he's a big comic
book fan he's just so good at what he
does and I thank them I couldn't thank
him enough because it was the week
before the book came out and that's also
responsible for multiple printings
because the reach of his audience is is
is great and it was just it was it was
one of those things that I never thought
I would have I'm I do in my life it but
it was it was utterly lovely and because
it was for a good cause I was it didn't
feel like gross self-promotion I was
there to help push the book first and
foremost yeah we do enough gross
self-promotion let me don't get me wrong
it was cool seeing my name on the door I
took my header on Facebook as me and
Taryn sitting on this show ll come down
soon it's gonna be kind of dickish if I
leave it up much longer but I wasn't you
know it was cool but it was all anything
to get to copy of the book soul is that
much more money helping someone out and
and the book I think is gonna change
people's minds I know so many people
that bought the book bought multiple
copies as gifts to give to loved ones
and you know reading the reviews on
Amazon and the text I get from people
saying wow I didn't think about this
this way or I'm three pages in and I'm
crying on the bus I have to read it when
I get home you know that's a win-win and
people all over the world I bought the
book I've gotten emails and texts and
Facebook things from people in Poland
from people in South Africa from people
in Asia from people all over the world
who were buying the book and responding
to it and that's ultimately what it's
about and it's awesome and there's gonna
be a charity auction yeah right at
Megacon yeah Megacon is May 25th through
28th and that's Saturday we're gonna do
an auction of a lot of the art and a lot
of the artists are gonna be there and
we're gonna have some exclusive lovers
love material there there's gonna be a
special cover there's a limited edition
only that's only available at the
Orlando Con I'm gonna make a pilgrimage
because I feel like I have to to the
club site I know that's gonna be rough
but you kind of have to pay your
respects there and yeah and the people
at Megacon couldn't be more
they've been so great I mean getting
they're gonna they're bringing in a ton
of people to support the book and really
really you know I've heard from PID you
know I did interviews with people the
news channels in Orlando and Lander
newspapers and and the gratitude for
doing something like this is just so
humbling that's awesome so what is next
this this we talked about Rockman we
talked about love is love which is
amazing seriously if you guys and it's
available it's in print now it's and
it's v printing I believe it's available
through Amazon your local comic book
store if you get it digitally there are
18 pages of content by big names that
just we didn't get them put in the book
we're gonna try and keep the book in
print as long as there is a lot for it
we were nominated for a GLAAD award so
and the Eisner nominations will be out
soon and once again that stuff I hope we
get because it would be a nice thank you
to all the artists and writers to work
to say they got to be a part of an
Eisner nominated thing and and any press
is good press
yeah there's keeping this out there in
the public eye as long as possible is a
good thing there's gonna be a signing at
WonderCon with there's gonna be a bunch
of the contributors there and there's
gonna be like a daily signing at the IDW
booth I'm doing a panel about it down
there but after that I'm we're finishing
up Batman 66 Meets Wonder Woman 77
that's awesome okay so now tell me tell
me this this nice little temporal trick
you're playing in Batman 66 and Wonder
Woman 77 well the moderately short
version of it is when Batman 66 came out
I went to lunch with Hank Canales who
was then running all the DC digital and
stuff and I said you got to do Wonder
Woman 77 you got to do the Lynda Carter
stuff and then a couple months later I
got an email saying we're doing it I'm
like who's doing it my name better be in
there I'm gonna go nuclear so I had to
write the first like eight chapters of
that and I had been bugging them to do
Batman 66 Wonder Woman 77 I'm like those
two worlds fit in very very easily and I
said but I only want to do it if I get
to work with Jeff Parker because Jeff
did the unenviable task of writing the
Batman TV show in a comic book and being
faithful to the colorfulness and the
positivity of it but I'm not making it
snarky or too cool for school or to
campaign but he captured it very well
and I said I wouldn't have had the idea
if it wasn't for Jeff's stellar work on
that so basically it's a digital first
book it's gonna be six issues of a comic
book the first two are out now in print
and the first two issues take place in
1944 which is the first season of Wonder
Woman so it's her at a USO auction at
Wayne Manor with ten year old Bruce
Wayne and Shorty and in the middle two
issues take place during the height of
the Batman show in 1966 and we go to
Paradise Island and then the last two
issues take place in 1977 where Bruce
Wayne has retired and Wonder Woman is
you see up there did Grayson Burt Ward
becomes Nightwing completely with
bell-bottoms chest hair and necklace and
a kung-fu collar and an evil Evel
Knievel bike so it's it's really close
to being like complete fan porn for me
but it's been a blast and David Hahn and
Carl kasell are doing the art and the
artist spec getting to work with Carl
key so I mean that's I've been a fan of
his since legends and I think he's after
Terry Austin like the best inker ever on
John Byrne and a great writer and artist
in his own right our editors Christie
Quinn Mike Dunn Laura all what are doing
the covers
we had Alex Ross - a variant cover for
the first issue that is just you know
it's just amazing so it's super super
super fun and that'll be wrapping up
digitally in the next two months and
then the last issue of the print layout
I can get you know after that I do I do
but as comic books go it's stuff you
know I can't talk about because
everybody thinks was more like nuclear
secrets
let me promote these things guys do so
there's a bunch of creator-owned stuff
that I'm working on that is is that
stuff I've wanted to do for a long time
and there's some stuff that I've been
talking to DC about some other like
bucket list stuff I've wanted to do and
and some other stuff for other companies
that you know I it's not me I'm not
trying to be oblique I would love to
talk about this stuff but right they
want to strike when the iron is hot with
press and you know the windows of those
things you know them the news cycles so
fast I have to wait but some stuff
should hopefully be announced yeah
WonderCon and at San Diego Con right
we're starting that like that weird
phase of press droppage [ __ ] yeah
where it's like alright for six months
there's gonna be a boatload of
announcements and
and I hate to be like the vague booking
guy like something really cool is
happening because usually when one of my
friends post that then I then they
reveal and they're like I got a discount
at Carl's jr. I'm like wait a minute
that's not something your Facebook about
if something cool happen is you're
writing a movie for Steven Spielberg
although I will say therefore for for
deal at Carl's jr. is kind of
outstanding it's almost as good at the
five five dollar chicken chalupa a Taco
Bell
if the taco is a fried chicken not
anymore
they pulled it off the shelves fast food
talk with Mark and Mark no I do like
their the arms race I'm like how can we
give the most fattening food to people
for the least amount of money well did
you see the Taco Bell is the healthiest
fast food out there now they did they
test it all of it and it was the
healthiest I don't know what the scale
how what they judge it against like time
from eating to coronary is the longest
and talk about more time for meeting to
toilet well flush your system are you
going to ever circle back into that
dream of film like is that still afect
oh there are stuff going on in that but
you know if film is is slow it's so slow
there are two big things that are
happening that and if you have to be
vague booking with comics you really
have to be big book again studios and
producers and money gets done' but
there's a couple of things that should
be announced within the next six months
that if they happen are ridiculously
cool life-changing cool um
if they're successful movies
life-changing cool if they if they get
made their life changing cool for the
next decade if they are successful their
life changing cool until I'm in the
ground kind of life-changing cool where
people start bringing you things from
the movie I've have enough residual
Catholicism that I don't think I'm ever
gonna be that person again we're gonna
be I'm never gonna be the first choice
for anything well yeah we'll see you
know this is this is a marathon it's not
a sprint you know and we get lots of
charley horses creatively when we're
doing this it's a it's a rough life but
you know we all chose it so I can't
complain too true you know I get I got
to be on Seth Meyers nobody on with the
high school with can say that fact they
would they would all gladly trade they
all have health insurance and own home
as I was on Seth Meyers sorry to eat the
earth exactly exactly
awesome well dude it was so good to have
you okay yeah absolutely
boys and girls out there go out and pick
this stuff up I mean I will I will say
from personal experience lovers love is
outstanding and you have a contribution
and I know I do I have a little story in
there I don't even remember what pages
but the pages are numbered so it doesn't
matter just read it all
read it all it's all good for you the
best kind of broccoli it's good for you
it tastes good it's good for you and
it'll really move you it's it's so it's
so beautifully done that I can remove
myself from the whole process and be
like this this anthology books are
always a crapshoot and anthology books
about real life incidents the odds of
them being good and this is something
that that is worth five times the cover
price and is a really profoundly moving
piece yeah I mean it is both executed
the highest level and it is not
cringe-worthy at all because we've read
I know I know I know well yeah you know
you don't want you're like oh wait a
minute
yeah and it's hard it's absolutely in
the right place so by all means love is
love den of Hawkman Batman Wonder Woman
go do that stuff mark thank you thank
you sir by the first cave that's it for
this week we had a special guest who
came and told the stories and we love
stories story time with Mark and Mark
that'll be the other podcast we're gonna
come on
I'm game just tell me when and where
fast food story time with Mark and Mark
we can be eating fast food as we tell
story I would be mu three episodes
before we die a limit a limited series
so that's it for this week come back
next week same time same fed channel
I've been mark Bernardi find us at
SModcast calm or youtube.com slash Kevin
Smith
[Music]
you
[Music]